t-minus three two one hello we're today
we're going to look at the consequences
and political impacts of going into
space and to assist me on my journey to
space we're going to talk about two
different publications one of which is
the NASA twin study that came out last
year and one of the more recent review
that looked at the impacts of space
travel on acquired immunity so let's
start with the twin study because why
not they have a really cool figure of
the T twins involved in the study anyway
within the study they did a multi
dimensional analysis of a year-long
human space flight and the question they
were trying to address is how does the
extreme environment which the space
actually affects human physiology and to
go into space is new one stressful event
it was actually very stressful and
there's a lot of hazards and stresses
that are involved and go into space and
to name just a few some of the major
stresses is microgravity which is the
feeling of weightlessness the impacts of
radiation the impacts of circadian
rhythm disruption so in this study the
twin that went to space was on the
International Space Station and say
obviously that orbits the earth and due
to the speed that they travel they
actually orbit the Earth and gave
through 16 sunrises and sunsets in the
space of one day and they speak briefly
before about how they're trying to
medicate that and additional stresses
include just the psychological stresses
of the affair and the loneliness and
also other stressors such as hypoxia and
say within the study they did a really
bad analysis of these T twins one which
stayed on earth and one that went to
space
they've them our astronauts and so this
is a good study because you've got that
genetic control
and say they did this study across 25
months that included the duration that
occurred in flight and then they look to
learn two different biological and
physiological readouts that included
things such as the transcriptome so the
different genes that are being expressed
and also like body mass and
cardiovascular differences and so when
they handled this data they then looked
at the changes of going to space and
then returning back to earth
and characterize these changes in thule
risk mid risk and high risk in terms of
health and so firstly let's look at the
lyric and say this is changes that they
saw that occurred during flight but
actually return back to normal after
flight and say these include changes in
the microbiome they interestingly saw an
increase in the telomere length which I
thought was really interesting but they
then returns back to a normal length
after returning back to earth and they
also saw apparently no major changes in
the immune system or they obviously will
come back to that later and so in terms
of the misc
health issues they saw alterations in
collagen regulation and intravascular
fluid management and so this is thought
to impact blood clotting and fast
culture changes and they also saw some
of the telomeres actually shortened and
then and so these middle risks occurred
much MIDI risk because they don't really
know the long term consequences could be
but there were also high risk as a Toms
health consequences in particular they
saw genomic instability and chromosome
rearrangements but they also saw changes
from the cardiovascular system probably
related to some of the Midwest changes
and also changes within the vision and
cognitive changes and so the results
were suggestive of cognitive decline
which as the states and the paper could
have implications for safe mission
operations such as after landing on Mars
and further supporting genomic
instability potentially caused by the
radiation was an operation of genes
involved in the DNA damage response so I
would say this study is very much a
descriptive study because they pretty
much just looked at the changes
this was only based on one set of twins
so it was a very limited study so what
can they actually complete from this
well one of the main observations they
make is that considering most things
remain stable human health can be mostly
sustained from going to space however
obviously we saw some high risk and mid
risk changes and so in the future they
need to look for waste and might get
these changes to prevents the biological
consequences especially considering
plans missions to Mars and so so far
we've looked at some of the challenges
in stage but if we figures more in
microgravity and radiation we can also
look at some more data that focus more
specifically on acquired immunity so in
terms of immunity in our bodies you can
kind of split into two so you have the
innate immune response and the acquired
or adaptive immune response so D innate
immune responses often referred to as
the rapid first line of defense that
includes things like your skin and your
mucus and macrophages which the cells
that gobble up other cells and speak
requires on the other hand it's more
adaptive and it causes inflammation and
this antigen dependence it depends on
the pathogen that got into the body and
relies on T and B cells and so these
cells lymphocytes cells
and they derive from the pain Mary and
the b-cells matured within the primary
but the t-cell was actually mature
within the thymus which is a different
organ and so to call a very long and
complicated story short when you have
pathogens within the body the innate
immune system gets activated which can
also lead to activation of the acquired
immune system which results in the
immune response and also development if
necessary of memory cells that provide a
long lasting immunity however some of
these processes are thought to be
affected by space flights so as I have
just described the bay marrow is really
important for development of these B and
T cells but as is known for many studies
the burden is heavily influenced by
reduced gravity such that in astronauts
they have a sharp decrease in bone mass
but the bone marrow also contains he
must appear tech stem cells and so these
are cells that can differentiate into
these B and T cells and so it is thought
that the impact of reduced gravity can
also impact the environment of the bone
marrow such that the differentiation
process could also be impacted so in
particular they've noticed a reduction
in wrote a activity and CSCL 12 which is
thought to reduce the stemness of these
stem cells but whether or not that makes
any sense the key thing is that
understanding how these processes are
impacting the immune response and bone
development will help in the development
of regenerative medicine not only for
astronauts but also for patients such as
those with osteoporosis but it is not
just the very Murray that seems to be
impacted by space travel studies have
also shown an impact on the thymus in
particular blood samples taken from
astronauts have shown that there's a
reduction in t-cell outputs and other
studies particularly done in rodents
that they can also model from are fusing
-
that's--and ways to alter the gravity
they've seen that there's thymic in
pollution and I mean I was just pointed
out heads that's interesting that I
previously speak about a trial that's
trying to improve dynamic inflation
because it's the condition that's
associated with age so you should check
out that video for more detail anyway
one question that you could be asking is
okay fine you see these potential
changes in T and B cells but does that
actually affect the onset of disease and
well actually so far based on current
reports there are new reports that I
seem to show you that astronauts are
more prone to developing serious
infectious seizing diseases during or
after spaceflight
however one study showed that astronauts
these days in a space shuttle for a
short period say 12 to 16 days before
during and after the flight exhibited a
reactivation of latent viral infections
and so these viral infections are found
in approximately 70 to 95 percent of the
global population and include things
such as the human harpy Cyrus and so
while most of these infections are
clinically asymptomatic there could be
potential long-term impacts that just
haven't been assessed yet moreover there
isn't enough data to support a link
between spaceflight and increased cancer
risk nonetheless given that there are
plans to go to Mars
while there's increased of radiation and
takes longer to get there
impacts on spaceflight should really be
investigated further to you understand
the bulk or in pounds and so I hope you
learned something and as always thanks
listening